the elevator to discourage people
and come at Columbus
truly feels oh
foreign
good morning
welcome to this session of the Berlin
science week on Mega Trends and future
research
what we are going to do is to offer you
an insight into Mega Trends Research
into future research
presenting very briefly our book and
then engaging with the panelists
Demetrios
margelos
Benning Garrett from the US very
seasoned Mega Trends researcher and
Victoria
Escobar here from Berlin Institute for
urban
policy research
in a panel discussion
what can you expect from this sessions
not much of Science Fiction but as I
said an introduction into Mega Trends
and future research
John nice pit was one of the pioneers of
Mega Trends researched
he published his books 10 directions
Transforming Our Lives in 1982
it sold more than 14 million copies in
50 countries and what he predicted was
the change from industrialization to
information societies
since then
a lot of strategy consulting firms and
think tank have ventured into the topic
of future research
researching on global Trends on and
future developments
Demetrius and myself we published this
book end of May this year on global
perspectives on megatrends
we wanted to be a bit more Global more
comprehensive and we wanted to also
collect perspectives from the global
south from we cooperated with think
tanks researchers and analysts from
different world regions
John nice pit had published his book on
the U.S but he has also provided
advisory services to many governments
and policy makers across the world
nowadays and we will hear more from
Benning Garrett
most of the governments especially in
the US in Canada and in Europe they work
together with think tanks and are very
keen on getting their advice on future
directions
why has it become so important to engage
in future research
our world has become Buca we live in a
wuka world volatile uncertain complex
and ambivalent and climate change of
course is the prime example we cannot
exactly predict what will happen with
planet Earth in 10 or 15 years but we
have robust data to tell us that we are
going to face severe challenges related
to the health of our planet and it's
much wiser to anticipate some of these
developments than wait and see
the covid-19 pandemic was another prime
example why it is important trying to
anticipate developments
and of course uh new technologies uh new
technological opportunities uh Big Data
artificial intelligence we need to be
prepared for big changes because those
changes will not just remain in the
domain of Technology but they will
impact Our Lives everybody's life
yeah
we have cooperated with uh think tanks
dengva Britain in German
with different countries and Nations
what is a think tank I mean when you ask
a German about think tanks some of them
are still a little bit skeptical they
would think about the Rand Corporation
in the U.S foreign and security policy
think tank or they would think about big
Lobby groups big money influencing uh
policies especially in the U.S but we've
witnessed a proliferation of new kind of
think tanks dimitrios is currently
working with the Zoe Institute a think
tank based in in Cologne and I've been
working with a couple of think tanks in
India in China in in other countries
yeah
that the global go to think tanks report
of the Pennsylvania uh University and
they list thousands of think tanks
there's also a ranking of these think
tanks
you see some big names and some of you
have come across these big names like
Carnegie Frugal and Chatham House of
course most of them still
in the US but even here in Germany and
in the global South you have a large
number of of of think tanks
what kind of conceptual
Frameworks are used to reflect and to
act on future challenges for Humanity
most of you are probably familiar with
the United Nations 2030 agenda for
sustainable development it was adopted
by all member states of the United
Nations at the 70s anniversary
Conference of the United Nations 2015 in
New York just three months ahead of the
Paris agreement
and it's a quite comprehensive agreement
in tailing not only the 17 sdgs but also
169 targets and more than 232 indicators
it's mainly promoted by the United
Nations and international organizations
a lot of international organizations
actually so-called custodian agencies
but also National governments
sub-national governments cities and you
will find reference to the sdg framework
in sustainability reports of almost all
multinational companies including the
financial industry but of course this is
a kind of a top-down approach which is
closely monitored by the United Nations
with targets and indicators that's
different than the mega Trends framework
which is more focusing on future
opportunities but opportunities and
risks are very closely related as the
world economic Forum uh pointed out they
have this Global risk reports which are
very prominent and they organize these
sessions in Davos where Business Leaders
and some head of states meet every year
there are also some other Frameworks
like the planetary boundary framework
which defines the safe operating space
for uh Humanity uh and it's basically
about the health status of of planet
Earth but let us focus a bit more on the
mega Trends framework which was kind of
kick-started by the work of John nysbit
yeah
in Germany you have a two conf Institute
they address a german-speaking audience
they don't publish much in English they
do wonderful work and we have also
cooperated with some of their experts
they visualize Mega Trends in a nice way
I just wanted to show you this picture
there are lots of similar diagrams on
Mega Trends whether you put the key
trends at the outskirts or at the center
of the metro map is discussable of
course but anyway it's nice to see and
good to digest
and we have worked with a pretty uh
simple but concise uh framework for
identifying this Mega Trends I mean the
mega Trends this course is mainly pushed
by consulting firms by McKinsey in
Germany Roland Berger Deloitte and so on
but they don't care too much in defining
the mega Trends they typically focus on
the tech Trends demography and uh
perhaps some equal Trends we wanted to
adopt Demetrius and we wanted to adopt a
more comprehensive approach to Mega
Trends and we looked at are these Trends
really covered by research worldwide do
they receive two Global political
attention for example by the G20
meetings
uh what is what is the interest of
Global Investors for the attention paid
by Global Investors to these Trends and
we looked at Global media coverage and
also uh social activists social
movements
we have eventually come up with 12 Mega
Trends climate action and sustainability
digitalization inequality
demography
urbanization and smart cities
health and nutrition
green economy
sustainable Finance multipolar World
Order democracy and governance
innovation
civilizational developments of course it
was most difficult to talk about
civilizational developments across
different cultures across different
political systems we have still
identified the diversity Trend
individualization and loneliness
gender shift and identity politics
and then we have migration
and we've written the book we've
finished the book end of May 2022 and it
looks like some of these Trends
Demetrius will talk about inequality uh
migration these Trends are yet to become
stronger and stronger
okay
I will not uh have the time to go deep
into the trends of course the climate
action Trend it's the first and biggest
chapter in our book it's about
investments in Renewables
it's about investment in carbon capture
and storage Technologies it's about
emission trading the cost-effective
combination of buying or selling
emission permits it's about carbon
neutrality strategies policies
electromobility
environmental social and governance
criteria for Investments
just let us have a look at how many
countries governments provinces
cities have subscribed to a
zero carbon carbon neutrality
according to confirmed pledges of the
carbon neutrality Coalition
733 cities 31 regions
3670 business and
173 of the biggest investors 600 622 of
higher education institutes including of
course fire universitate Berlin I think
we were one of the first to commit to
carbon neutrality
have and there's a race to carbon zero
campaign you you can say so that shows
you how deep and how broad this trend is
major consulting firms are also doing a
lot of work on decarbonization
strategies and uh if you're if you
believe you can ignore that Trend or you
uh you can ridicule this trend then you
will fear some some severe consequences
like the head of the uh of a major Bank
HSBC in in Britain he was fired after he
gave a speech saying that uh the credit
cycle of a bank spends for only six
years
sometimes eight years and that the
consequences of climate change would not
that seriously impact the work of his
bank and that was not acceptable because
any of the big banks are supposed to
play a leading role nowadays in in
designing climate action plans
yeah
I'm having a slide of one of our guests
Jana lipenkova and she's engaging in
ai-based artificial intelligent based
monitoring of megatrends what we have
done and Demetrius will tell you later
is we have talked and talked with
experts from different countries regions
from different disciplinary backgrounds
we have read a lot of reports from the
world economic Forum other Flagship
reports Carnegie from consulting firms
that's the way we identified the trends
and the sub Trends but there's also
opportunity to it to do it in a
different more technology Savvy way and
if you want to say a few words about
about it you can just come and before we
hand over to dimitrios
because Jana has to has to leave earlier
thank you uh yeah thanks a lot bartol
for um
mentioning Anna code which is my company
and basically we were really excited by
the publication of the book by bartol
and dimitrios and this is why we also
took the initiative to propose some
cooperation so
um the thing is that at Anna code we
work in a data driven manner also we
really try to Monitor and conceptualize
the mega Trends currently we have a
focus on digitalization and
sustainability using data so most of the
information that we get about Mega
Trends is information that can be found
online in different kinds of
Publications so starting with the
scientific press but then also going
into the business press then
um consumer Publications and so on and
we really believe that that's important
to monitor this information on a global
and dynamic Pages because the trend is
always something that's Dynamic and the
research study using classical
methodology that you do today it will be
basically outdated in some months or
well let's say maximally a year and
that's why we really believe it's very
important to monitor the mega Trends
themselves but then also to see what are
actually the topics that constitute the
mega Trend yeah because now we have for
instance this big topic of
digitalization but what are the main
Technologies like cyber security AI
Aerospace and so on that make up this
trend and we really believe that there
are many interactions with everything
else that's going on in the world and
there you really need the data driven
and AI based methodology to model all of
this dynamically
thank you very much Jana and we are now
proceeding to our methodology and of
course we also focused on how these
Trends these Mega Trends are seem
intersected with each other and I think
dimitrios will focus on the intersection
of the climate action
and sustainability digitalization and
inequality
and also gender uh gender shift Trends
so the flow is yours right
um so one thing
um that we want to acknowledge is that
this book was developed through an
understanding of diversity of opinions
and Beyond the 37 expert interviews and
that we integrated into the book from
diverse backgrounds diverse fields of
research whom we are incredibly thankful
for I'd also like to take a small moment
to think to people also in the audience
who helped us with their expertise and
their knowledge namely John Andy and
Shane
um but yeah it's kind of no mistake that
we lean towards diversity because we are
not experts on any given field that we
write on and we believe that to write
sort of a global history of the future
you need to integrate the very voices
that will shape it and it's not enough
to just talk about the global South and
integrate say one or two voices for the
purposes of diversity because what we
forget is that when we talk about the
global South we are in fact talking
about the global majority a significant
one at that and one that in the future
will be much more pronounced so as we
kind of dissected the work of think
tanks researchers activists academics
investors Etc we did not want to develop
a rigorous almost ineligible methodology
um by which to identify the megatrends
and instead wanted to have the book be
available to a wider audience which is
why we came to the Pentagon model
perhaps we can also have the slide and
through these five criteria we ended up
identifying these 12 Mega Trends which
importantly for today is that the fact
that they intersect and reinforce one
another
um specifically in regards to
inequalities which is kind of the the
field that I'm working on
and if we want to get into the Nitty
Gritty of it one thing that I would like
to get out of the way in regardless
inequality is that it is it does not
come about naturally it is rather a
result of human processes beliefs and
systems the most well-established one at
that being the Western market economy
which produces vast inequalities
um which we then in the aftermath decide
percentage-wise how much we want to
alleviate them through the rigorous and
vast redistribution programs in the
welfare systems pioneered by the
Europeans in the 19th and 20th Century
either in Scandinavia with the
coalitions or with bismarck's ulterior
motives but even the welfare systems are
not set in stone as countries nowadays
have proven
um so for example India and Brazil these
have programs NDS job programs for
example are very successful in doing
exactly what they're meant to do getting
people a lot of slums getting them into
work well in Brazil they have Innovative
programs that Target mothers and tie the
benefits to the children's education as
well as annual checkups
so whatever the case may be it is true
that we have chosen an economic system
that produces inequalities but then we
have also chosen societal beliefs that
amplify and exacerbate those and it is
when you apply the gender lens on these
Trends Mega trends that you get even
more worrying results especially when it
comes to inequalities so one thing that
is talked about quite a lot is for
example the wage Gap and as much as
people would like it to not exist it is
true that on average over the span of
her lifetime a woman will earn much much
less in comparison to a woman simply
because she inhabits a body that bears
children and when policy does not take
this into account of course this is
disregarding the unpaid labor that
essentially costs women 10.9 trillion
dollars globally yearly then you get
things like less paid time off work less
maternal leave less promotions
um that and sometimes even a complete
exit from the labor market
um after having children and of course
their studies for example from the ILO
that say that people should not be
working more than 45 hours
um a week this does not take into
account the the physical
um toll that unpaid labor which is done
overwhelmingly by women has on them
um in that regard Japan is one of the
worst offenders especially when it comes
to Promotions due to the work culture of
you know having to stay late having to
go for drinks Etc that does not take
again into account the unpaid labor and
then if we look at Scandinavia we see
what I would like to call and sort of
econ 101 Paradox because standard
economic theory postulates that if
there's High income taxes then people
will be decentralized to go to work but
instead we see a positive correlation
between in high income taxes and labor
market participation for women
specifically because how you use that
money is very important when you put it
back into Child Care into these rigorous
programs and as we talked about in
Brazil it is the same thing during the
economic boom they invested quite
heavily into their education of the
children and that's how you get a
booming middle class meanwhile in the US
you lose about a trillion a year
um simply due to child poverty that's 28
of the federal budget and the gender
lens though does not stop there it's not
simply about economic inequalities and
if we construct cities in the future
smart cities that allow for women's
abuse for example on the streets through
blind spots they're like in New Delhi
which is the case or if we look at the
health care sector where we want to push
for digitalization or we want AI to take
over we are those we haven't done proper
Research into women's bodies and
diseases we are effectively cementing
the very same biases that we currently
have
and we simply cannot afford to think in
the same ways that we have been taught
to so all of these large changes and
challenges enable us to observe that we
create the world that we see and it is
also vital that we uphold these
democratic values and we try to
integrate as many people as possible
into this challenging future because the
things that we talk about the circular
economy it cannot stand if the links are
not stable and
um similarly I mean the planet will not
survive if it is only enjoyed by the few
and a controversial thesis as we have
found out in the book is that everyone
is a shaper but that can only be true if
people are empowered to do so and money
is power and that can turn into
political power very quickly and so when
we talk about a living in inequalities
we're not just talking about taxation
we're not just talking about these
things what we are talking about is
empowering the very same people to
create sort of the future and I guess
with that I can over Banning
great terrific and I think we didn't
introduce you very properly Demetrios I
mean Nature's is is a is a political uh
activist still a student and he's with
the soe Institute which is a
cologne-based think tank and of course
Benning Garrett has still much more to
say about his life he's a very seasoned
Mega Trend researcher he has advised the
US government traveled over 60 times to
China but I would ask you to introduce
yourself in the same uh for uh Veronica
Victoria before you start your talk so
please I think Banning will just
underscore the relevance and also the
future of megatrends research why is it
become so important to become future
literate yeah not just understanding the
history but also understanding the
future
thank you beautiful
um well I don't know exactly what to say
about myself except I
I've had a kind of varied experience
including the China experience going
there every year Well starting in 1981
some 60 trips uh carry on a kind of
unformal strategic dialogue between the
U.S and China and many other things but
one of the things that most relevant for
here is work on global Trends and I'll
give you a little background on that
from the U.S government
activities in that fair one thing I
wanted to say is kind of a paradox I
think
that underlies all this I don't think
we've ever known as human beings have
never known more about the future
and never known less
and the Paradox we have a tremendous
we've wired up the planet with the
Internet of Things We have incredible
knowledge of what's going on day by day
on the planet whether it's the North
Pole Antarctica all kinds of evidence
we're able to understand those trends of
where things are going the ipcc beam
example of certainly tremendous effort
at trying to understand the future of
the climate and pick people are doing
extraordinary work on the nine
boundaries on the environment and then
we look at the mega Trends these Global
trends that we can see demographic
Trends and I'll talk about that and and
migration and all this but we have less
idea of what's going to be happening
than ever I mean we are in a very
complex interactive period in human
history and this month I think we just
hit eight billion people on the planet
each with their own lives their own
perspectives their own interests all
trying to somehow get along uh well not
necessarily trying to get along
um but in any case it's it's a very
complex system and trying to that's
where the global Trends fit in because
we can foresee trends but what the hard
part is how they interact and what do
they produce in terms of you know
foreseen a war uh you know Russia
attacking trying to seize Ukraine you
know we have so many different things
going on in the world that we didn't
necessarily
predict
although we could foresee that the
trends the context and I think that's
really important to make that
distinction and going back to the
question of global Trends in the US
government probably very few people here
know heard of the National Intelligence
Council in the United States in fact a
lot of people in Washington have not
heard of the National Intelligence
Council yet it's the Supreme uh
organization that stands over the 17
intelligence agencies of the US
government to provide analysis and a
perspective a presidential Daily Brief
that has National Intelligence Officers
on all the key countries on key issues
like proliferation or climate or
whatever and it and one of the things
that that
affected this and really how we got into
Global Trends so the US government did
is it in the Cold War U.S intelligence
Community was really focused on the
Soviet Union and focused on nuclear
weapons Maneuvers all these things that
were secret you had to have spies you
had to have overhead you know
reconnaissance to try to find what's
going on this was the focus
with the end of the Cold War in the
early 90s they started realizing boy
there's all these other things out there
that are threats or concerns for
National Security that we really don't
know very much about because we've been
so focused on all these secrets from
whether you know not just uh the Soviet
Union but mainly looking at these kind
of clandestine things in a very kind of
static bipolar world
so they said oh there's all this stuff
going on out there that we have to find
out about ultimately it becomes
urbanization it becomes climate change
it becomes you know other kinds of
sources of conflict it becomes all kinds
of issues so they said well we have to
kind of we don't know about all this
stuff and the experts are outside the
government and by the way as you still
have to pound on these intelligence
people and say about 98 of what you need
to know is not secret it's just out
there you can open press you can go talk
to people you can go find out what they
think and it's one of the things I did I
went and talked to the Chinese about
what was going on what do they think
about SDI about the U.S about Japan or
whatever and they'll actually talk to
you and tell you you don't just have to
send spies in or you know find secrets
so what they did is they started these
Global Trends reports the first one was
I think released in 97 and it was called
Global Trends 2010. and I highly
recommend going to just Google Global
Trends maybe there's 20 2010 2015 2020
2025 2030 for some reason the 2035 one
they didn't put 2035 and then the most
recent 2040. and you'll they all come up
they'll be on the National Intelligence
Council page and you can download them
they're they're absolutely unclassified
that's what they realize go out there
and talk to the world it doesn't have to
be classified just find out what people
think and try to put it together so they
started doing this and after the 2020
report came out in 2004 they oh the
other thing about it these reports would
be published every four years after the
U.S presidential election so there was
and before the president took power in
order one so it wasn't political you
didn't know who was going to be elected
and secondly it was like a strategic
document for the new Administration that
was the original idea and and it
continues to be one of the main reasons
for the reports but so they they decided
they had to go out and I I read this
report in 20 2004 was the global Trends
2020 and I was at the Atlantic council
at the time and I convinced a friend who
was a chairman of the National
Intelligence Council let's take this
report around the world to get Global
input so it's not just a bunch of
Americans sitting in a room in Langley
Virginia figuring out what are the
trends out there let's go talk to people
find out what they think I mean it
really is you know part of what what
you've worked on both of you and uh so
we went to over between 2006 and 2012 we
went to I don't know 20 countries some
many times like China Russia uh I mean
every continent and and we would
organize meetings with think tanks and
government it would bring in government
officials academics business people and
try to sit down for two or three days
and just talk about how what do you see
as the major Trends affecting the world
and trying to look out 10 or 20 years so
it's not just the current trends but
where are they going and so they produce
I think actually some very good reports
as I said they were completely public
they're the Chinese loved them and they
translate them within about a month
they'd be in Chinese but they've been
used by by certainly governments all
over the world uh and it's they're kind
of a gold standard although I would add
that the the defense Concepts and
development center of the UK Ministry of
Defense produces something called Global
strategic Trends every five years and
they're very very good and these and
these are people who are looking Beyond
just narrow National Security interests
they're looking to you know like I said
urbanization migration certainly climate
change resource scarcities what sources
of conflict because we have to
understand this this world that's
evolving and and the the context because
the the threats to security aren't just
uh well right now we're hearing a lot
about nuclear weapons uh presumably
Putin won't be that stupid but in any
case they're coming back into Focus but
the point being that there's a lot of
issues that threaten our security I mean
the flooding the fires all the things
coming out of climate change so these
reports were been been issued and they
like I said they come out every four
years they're used by the in fact after
the guy that I'd worked with who wrote
the global Trends 2025 I guess it was he
flew to Chicago to brief about Barack
Obama just after he was elected the
first time on these Global Trends Obama
wanted to understand what are we facing
what are the trends out there crisis you
know sort of dangers and opportunities
and the opportunities part I think is
really important so in any case the uh
these Trends reports have had mixed
impact it's very hard for governments to
think long term and to actually
implement it and a felony of neon Firth
who was National Security adviser to Al
Gore and it should have been National
Security advisor in the United States
anyway he worked for years on what he
called anticipatory governance how do
you embed people in like white house and
other institutions whose job it is to
look down the road so the point being
here there are alternative Futures out
there that you know it's what we're
going to create is Mark said you know
humans make their own history but not
under conditions of their own choosing
so what are those conditions what do we
want where do we want to go or put it a
different way if we choose this policy
what path does that put us on if we want
to go over here instead of over here
what would we do today to move us in
that direction
uh what we if we wanted to be
independent of Russian gas would we have
a Nord stream one and two uh you know I
mean to put it kind of in Blunt terms
but this kind of ability to think about
well what are the alternative Futures
what a credible possible Futures that we
might or might not want so what are the
ones you don't want so you want to look
at your policies is that going to lead
you in a Direction you don't want to go
or you want to be in another place and
you know is that leading you in that
direction so I think this is the the
value of this is really critical for an
individual person in their own life for
an institution for a business for a
government for the global community and
I I think I'm probably running too long
here I would just add that that we are
at a very
the perhaps the key question I always
say that the biggest threat
to human civilization I think is our
inability to cooperate because if you
look at the things we're facing climate
change the entire environmental the
ecosystem being threatened the the on
top of scene which is humans creating a
new planet environment that we may not
like if we can't cooperate we are not
going to be able to meet these
challenges and I'll just mention here as
the last thing that when we went around
the world doing Global Trends we tried
to commit convince people to do their
own Global Trends to create a community
of people in their countries to look at
these Global Trends and I always had
this dream that we'd have a global
global Trends Community then we'd issue
a report like the ipcc that would be
with Indians and and Chinese and
Russians and Europeans and Africans and
South Americans and you know say hey
these are the big things you need to
worry about and do and then have some
credibility well that never never
happened but we did encourage I had a
friend in China who got money from the
the Ministry of Education to do a global
Trends 2030 report back in 2011. and it
was very good he invited me to be a
consultant on it to listen to their
their vetting of their draft and it was
amazing because well the trends are the
trends it's like the the laws of physics
don't change when you go to Benin or
Moscow you know there's still the laws
of physics and the trends are still the
trends so they were very similar so we
agreed and we got funding to do a joint
assessment of global Trends in 2012 2013
where we look together what are these
Trends and we wrote a report together
and we but my my reason for pushing it
the reason I wanted to do it because I
thought if you look at the big Global
Trends you say hey we're in the same
boat if we don't work together on
climate change especially China and the
United States since we're the biggest
powers and the biggest polluters if we
don't work together you're not going to
get really viable Global uh cooperation
so that was a point of the report and we
signed off with oh this was really this
is you know really crucial for the two
countries to work together we had the
endorsement of three former National
Security advisors Brent gocroft and
Hadley and Jones the former foreign
minister of China Lee jausing and Tang
Joshua so high-level people endorse this
idea the U.S and China should have a
strategic framework that cooperation on
these issues was the the basis strategic
basis of our relationship and then we
can disagree on all the other stuff
right well of course here we are 10
years later and where are we it's quite
that went nowhere uh and that report is
still on the Shelf it's a good idea and
it had a lot of support at the time but
particularly with Xi Jinping I think
it's taken China in a very different
direction and we have not helped so
we're not there but the point being that
we have to figure out how do we
cooperate as human beings to deal with
these challenges because we can't
foresee them
and we could see the the alternative
Futures we could go very bad direction
or maybe a much better Direction so I
better stop there but I'll have some
comments on some science fiction
approaches to that problem so anyway
that's my Michael thank you thank you
Benning I think it's important to say
that we don't have exact data on how the
future will look like but still we have
a lot of robust information and data
that certain developments like climate
change or technological developments
will definitely happen you must have
realized that we have a pretty diverse
panel not exactly for Generation that
would be exaggerated but I would say
four four age groups yeah people and now
we come to Victoria Escobar Heredia who
is a researcher with the Institute force
and I was very happy to exchange viewers
with her on one of our earlier Mega
Trends and future research sessions at
The matsanata Institute a civil society
Think Tank here in Berlin and she's
doing a lot of work with young people
she's the chairperson of Shula Parton
and she will give us her perspectives on
future Trends and how important they are
for the younger generation
yeah good morning thank you
um exactly you already explained a bit
what I'm doing
um I am my field of interest is actually
your sustainability conveying inequality
and education is actually my main issue
and as you mentioned I'm I'm chairperson
of Shula Patton Berlin if how we offer
mentoring for students from Arabic
families low-income families and we
provide them with the local Berliner a
tutor who support them in school related
stuff and
um the idea is that
beyond that they also engage in Leisure
and cultural activities and the tutoring
takes place at the children's home so we
also want to
strengthen Intercultural exchange
because many of our volunteers don't
really have contact to to maybe people
from Arabic families or or also
low-income families
so actually at maybe Shula part what we
do or how where our work shapes the
future is that we try to convey
educational Equity uh contribute not and
conveyed inequality I'm sorry and
through the Intercultural exchange we
also contribute to social cohesion and
we try to widen the perspective of the
of the volunteers and also the students
help them to find their way into society
and actually we try to learn like that
it's a in exchange like to learn from
each other and to understand each other
better
um
yes for also for the volunteers is often
really important to understand the life
reality of the children because they
maybe don't know much about them and for
the children it's really important that
they have someone they can speak to
someone who is just there listens to
them has like interest in them
and um also maybe to get a new
perspective on climate action or on on
culture because some of our students
they born maybe in Berlin or they're
migrants and they actually they don't
never come out of their neighborhoods
because yeah maybe the families don't
have the ability to get to travel or to
do many cultural activities
and so the volunteers can be a bit of a
role model for the for the children and
can
um yeah help them on their educational
and their career planning
I really yeah I'm really convinced that
education is really one important key
for combating inequality and to get to
sustainable development because as
demonologists already said yeah
especially the young people will shape
the future like it's everyone is a
shaper somehow and as we heard there are
many uncertainties dilemmeters how can
we
have for example
um a general well-being or sustainable
development but how can we also ensure
economic stability and
to understand his complex into
connected
um
issues of a constant changing world it's
really important to equip them with with
what we can somehow call Future literacy
like how can I learn
to learn how can I explain problems how
can I answer my questions and therefore
it's really important for us to identify
an issue or problem than to analyze it
further to then be able to act like to
to
Empower them and not to overwhelm them
by all these insecurities maybe or or
uncertainties yesterday we also went to
a talk and we learned that we maybe
should embrace uncertainty that can be
maybe yeah controversial but I think
that's a bit also with the future like
it opens up much opportunities to shape
also the future so actually
um
yeah it's important to to support young
people to become actors of change like
to to shape the future and therefore I
really like one concept of Global
Learning because I think that you can
really combine and address social
economic and also ecological topics and
I think it's really important to link
that to the life reality of the Learners
like what does this has to do with me
like how can I maybe influence or also
what are things that I don't have
control of so I can maybe take distance
from it and not say that's my
responsibility Maybe
um yes so I really through my work
um an experience of course top-down
processes are really important but I
really believe in the things I've bought
them up
um project and work and yeah maybe we
can also see crisis like
um climate crisis or now a Health crisis
to as well as an opportunity how we can
shape the future
yeah thank you Victoria uh indeed the
concept of Global Learning is very
important education is key
and we have been talking a lot about
think texts but I think the younger
generation of think tanks they prefer to
call themselves think and do tanks yeah
and we at fire only visited Berlin we
are not only doing research on and
teaching about climate action and
sustainability but if I only visited
Berlin is also leading in green Campus
Management
I think we saved more than 6.5 million
euro because we have put Energy
Efficiency measures and solar panels on
our Bungalow Silva labor rostlava
building in in dalim and today the fire
only visited Berlin is is very active in
various alliances Europa for example or
uh it's a Europe Alliance of 11 European
universities or University Alliance for
sustainability it comprises five
universities including taking University
and Hebrew University in in British
Columbia University and Saint Petersburg
University yeah so thinking and acting
Global is is very key and that's what we
have been trying in cooperation with our
research Partners our partners from
business we have conducted more than 30
interviews so in each of the chapter you
will find one or two interviews people
from different background here at the
panel we have dimitrios born in Athens I
think you have double nationality
Colombian and and German uh
Benning is from the Banning is from the
US I'm I'm from Germany we have all
traveled the world like many of our
experts it was not easy to contact them
we've done the work
during the the covid-19 pandemic we had
online interviews with all of them but I
think it worked pretty well and from
Switzerland to Mexico to China India we
have tried to capture relevant voices
working on think tanks of course the
world has changed especially after
February
24th we have kind of predicted an
emerging multi-polar World Order rather
than the bipolar world order that could
be one issue for discussion but the
floor is now open we have plenty of time
to discuss to engage with you in a good
discussion on global trends please
introduce yourself with a few words and
then ask your question and we have no
moderator but we will try to manage in
between us
a little time
hi um my name is Russell Uncle Dave
um
I don't know formal education and part
of my work connected with Futures work
so I have two questions one to the all
all the panelists or one of the
panelists since the topic of these two
days is Paradigm Shift what paradigms
shifts do you notice now nowadays and
second one to the authors of the book of
the research
what is what differentiates your
research from all the other research you
presented or which are out there what's
the let's call it like UVB unique value
prepositioning select Point yeah I
didn't want to put the selling point
value proposition but okay selling point
thank you no thank you very much for
this question I think uh Dimitris will
also answer but I will I will go first
is that
we wanted to be first of all we wanted
to be more Global because we realized
that most of the mega Trends research is
done by Western uh
strategy consulting firms focusing more
on business or investment opportunities
of course it's very important to know
about Mega trends when you want to
invest here or when when you want to
learn about new business models but I
think there's there are many other
dimensions to Future Global Trends
social Dimensions yeah and we wanted to
also uh research on them that's why
Demetrius came in with his expertise in
inequality research we also included
migration and all all these
civilizational points we also wanted to
be a little bit more comprehensive I
mean
uh defining what is the Mega Trend or
trying to Define what is a mega Trend
that's usually not done when you read
the McKinsey uh report even the
battlesman foundation uh report of
course we value uh the work of of those
think tanks I mean the Germans Institute
is doing a lot of good Pioneer work but
they are addressing a German audience
yeah it's all written in German and I
don't see any voices from the global
South yeah so that's maybe the unique
selling point of our book we have a few
copies available if you want to buy one
or we have these these fancy cards with
a code yeah so you can just grab one
it's just 15 Euro the e-copy this one is
24. and yeah I think that's that's what
distinguishes us from
I mean there's a couple things that
always spring to mind
um when it comes to Unique selling
points um the thing that I always say
kind of to that question is you can
definitely Google McKenzie Megatron
whatever you want and then you'll get
enough information on it but what we
offer is exactly the idea that it
shouldn't be sort of a consultancy
um defining singularly what the mega
trend is and it should be a number of
people from all diverse backgrounds and
different fields of research that come
together and say here's what I think on
this here's where we're heading and
here's where I think you know this
country is heading this region setting
Etc and the thing that I've also started
thinking about is that maybe the
contribution of our book is also the
fact that we get into these dialogues
with people the fact that we we don't
exactly write a report post it on social
media or kind of you know disseminated
to the right people policy makers right
people in that sense but instead we kind
of you know ask people what their
opinion is we we want to be out there
kind of talking to people all the time
and seeing what they think what they
believe they can do sort of have that as
a reference as well if you want to get
into a field and you know want to do
your own work in it
that would be my the excelling point I
guess
when I read uh your the megatrends your
book I thought was pretty unique that
you've not only identified the trends
but you identify what people were trying
to do about them and then you also
included excerpts of interviews with
people from all over the world about the
trend and I don't know that any I
haven't seen any other study that that
worked that way I thought that was very
good I thought it was very exciting most
of the challenges I mean the book has an
interview with the chief executive of
nature Seychelles he's very active in
global climate action conferences but of
course the Seychelles face a problem
because they don't have their tool they
live on on on air passengers you know
and so there are a lot of dilemmas we
also address in this book yeah second
oh
Mike whenever when it doesn't work just
get a bigger work now yeah
excellent my name is I'm an immunologist
but I'm training and I'm actively
working in health for future and cluck
which is a German Alliance of climate
change and health and my question is a
little bit provocative maybe because I
was wondering who is sitting in those
think tanks because just looking at you
and I see there's one woman and three
men and I was wondering if the mega
Trends are made by I mean who is really
sitting in there because I see there
could be a slightly different
um maybe output at the end if people
would have been asked according to what
is really I mean the people according to
the percentages who are living on Earth
and this is my question how could you
make sure that really all
um
people are represented by those
thinkings maybe you can give a
perspective and I would also like to
understand this from you maybe you also
sit there too
Emily Benson come on Victoria get back
down here Emily Benson from the queen of
Club I do you want me to Let's Demetrios
the mega Trends Community uh like many
other uh policy circles are probably
still a little bit male dominated I mean
we tried uh to reach out to very diverse
think tanks I mean I remember one
interview with the green economy
Coalition important interview in the
chapter on green economy it's we talked
to Emily Benson I mean there are lots of
female voices in our book at least yeah
I think we try to have a good diversity
in terms of age in terms of gender in
terms of professional discipline country
background you know and that's very
important and that's also one of the
unique selling points of our book to
adopt this Global Perspective I mean we
we could have done better I tell you
very frankly it was most difficult for
us to get interviews in east east and
south East Asia because of hierarchy
issue you know we wanted to talk to a
think tank in South Korea and we had to
talk to the boss but he was not
available so it's sometimes difficult
even in Ministry in Germany a vice
Minister would not
just talk to you I mean the IMF people
you know they would not get clearance
from their top senior levels to just
give an interview for a book project
there are some exceptions but hierarchy
of course I mean University professors
and think tankers you know they can
speak more freely they want to promote
themselves Maybe
uh and yeah there are still too few
women out there with enough
free time also to engage in such
a project work but I think we did a good
job in
collecting diverse voices
I mean I'd like to answer your question
too and because I think it's a very
very deep problem first of all you're
right I mean if look at Washington where
I was working I mean it's almost
almost all male all white males that
we're doing is sitting around unlangely
that's one of the reasons of course we
wanted to go out
all over the world and so we Diversified
in terms of of race ethnicity and
national origin
that was good but who are you talking I
mean it's it's two things first of all
it wasn't very many women wherever we
went in fact the word most places there
weren't any women like China and most in
Africa very very few women
um and secondly it's class who are you
talking to
so you're talking to to men who are the
doc in the in the upper middle class or
official class or academic class and and
particularly in countries other than
this in the global South they're they're
very different presumably the people
living in villages people and living in
kibera and and Kenya and Nairobi uh so
it's a both the gender and a class
problem so you're not getting that
perspective on their future and in its
age I mean most of the global Trends you
know things I was in uh meetings we have
are probably the youngest person maybe
in the early 30s but most of them in the
50s and 60s and and of course it's the
hierarchy problem particularly you know
you get to in in Russia or in China in
these places it's the senior people and
then you get the problem well only the
senior people will talk in the group you
know because everybody's afraid to say
something in front of somebody else and
so you have a real problem getting not
just gender but gender of women and
people who are out there whose future is
being being shaped by these other people
so I think that's a really really
serious problem but we've not I mean I
think they've made a great effort to try
to overcome this but it's
just beginning and then I look at this
room which gives me hope it's about
two-thirds women
if you just go around and count I think
it's about I don't know at one point I
counted 36 women here because I was sort
of looking around and and I think more
women need to get into the the field and
it needs to be encouraged and opened and
all that but I also think what
Victoria's doing is the younger people
let's start with the youngest the
children and the high school students
and college students and getting them to
see not only to do future studies but to
think about the fact that first of all
this world is changing I wrote a piece
for for the Atlantic Council 10 years
ago it was technology is changing
everything and doing it faster
and we have this acceleration of
technological change I mean I'm an old
guy we had a dial telephone in my house
right you know even a party line at one
point and then a black and white
television set and then Along Came much
later something called a cell phone
which was a big brick right and then you
know you guys you know most people now
just grow up this is you know this is
old Tech right I mean everybody's got
this so it's a very rapidly changing
world and that's just in some of the
technology but the impact is is huge and
it's changing faster and faster so how
do you get young people who are their
their world is changing all the time
right oh it was Tick Tock last week
maybe Something's Gonna Be Something
Else next week right so they're
accustomed to the fact that things
change but they need to understand these
larger Trends because they don't want to
just be victims of the change or just
passively accepting it but shaping it
and understanding Alternatives and
ultimately you raise the question of the
economic alternatives
I mean that's something you know we're
in a very highly unequal and
increasingly unequal global economy you
know Washington consensus and all that
and the economic system has to change if
it's going to be viable because it's
creating you know conflict it's the
populism all the many of the things that
are happening in particular in my
country which is moving toward fascism
uh certainly very strong fascist
movement in the United States and uh
it's terribly worrisome to me but that's
part of the technological change it's
part of the high inequality there's a
whole lot of things going on here this
is very rare and the more that young
people can understand
this very rapidly changing World these
intersections of these different uh
factors I think the more they can help
them shape their own Futures but shape a
broader future and see that that the the
given is not the only alternative you
can change things they are being changed
and you can decide well what change do
you want where do you want the future to
go that's that's feasible and how do you
get there so I think the generations and
frankly I know this sounds trite but I I
think only the women can save us now
frankly that's my view because I think
that women have to be much bigger and
dominant voice perhaps in politics and
and and so much of our Lives because I
think that the I have more trust in the
Judgment not all women or anything like
that but I just think there's a very a
very big need to have a different kind
of leadership a different kind of a
perspective that tends to become more
from women to women I've known anyway in
in leadership positions so I'm very big
on this this change has to him so what
your question you asked it represents
all these issues but it's absolutely
critical and it's very important to see
when we look at these Global Trends
reports who were the people that put
them together who were questioned who
were you know who are part of the and do
they really represent
you know how somebody in a favela and
and Rio de Janeiro is thinking about
their future and what's possible so
anyway that's that's my two cents on
that question yeah we have we have more
questions I see thank you no first of
all thank you for the introduction to
megatrends the presentation
um going back to the Paradox the future
Paradox where we have on one side uh
future as a result of collaboration but
on the other side we should expect this
multi-polarized world what or in your
experience how is the how willing our
countries to work together leading
living their difference besides for
example in your experience with China
and USA or
foreign
[Music]
and myself we are a political scientists
uh by training and we try to be extra
careful in writing the chapter on
multi-lateralism and uh on on yeah and
the future of international cooperation
I think if you have traveled the world
and all of us have traveled the world I
mean you we were not surprised to say
that relatively few countries
unfortunately joined the sanction regime
of the West on Ukraine and the world we
believe that the world is not moving
into a simple bipolar world order again
we talk about
multi-polar World Order which is still
resented by many political leaders here
in Germany I mean
if you read the book you know that China
Russia and India are deeply entangled in
a couple of Institutions such as the
brics the Asian investment
infrastructure Bank the belt and Road
initiative the new development
initiative and so on so if you know
about these initiatives if you know
about these structures you are not
surprised that China even so uh Xi
Jinping is not a fan of Putin rather
vice versa rather the other way around
but
it's going to be very difficult but
there are still a lot of cooperation
going on I mean we are approaching the
cop 27 conference in charmele Sheikh
very moral yeah very soon and
000 40 000 people will attend that
conference from different strands of
society I mean it it started off as a
meeting among diplomatic leaders you
know but you have so many side events
you know and even when Donald Trump
withdrew from the Paris agreement I mean
climate action was still going on in the
U.S at the provincial level at the city
level at the business level even faster
than before you know I mean so it's
sometimes our media focus on you know
big government uh politics Sensational
news and now a lot of attention
attention is paid on the
re-ideologization of of China of course
it's true China faces a lot of uh
challenges but uh
perhaps I mean
a few months or a few years later I mean
the it's it's hard to predict if the
ideological grip will really reach out
to to each and every place in China and
shape the economy China used to be like
the the wild west of capitalism it used
to be pretty liberal and and and and
free and then covid-19 came and was a
kind of a uh Game Changer and also of
course uh the new regime but it's
difficult to anticipate and it's good to
continue with the pragmatic spirit and
seize opportunities and we cannot save
the world or shape the world uh climate
new technologies pandemics we need
Global cooperation and there are still
Avenues and thousands of experts are
engaged in such work
that I would uh I I tend to kind of joke
that we have the the four mads you know
Mutual assured nuclear destruction which
became the acronym NAD but we have a
mutual assured economic destruction
Mutual assured climate destruction and I
would add Mutual assured cyber
destruction and all these areas
the climate can get us a wall right it's
a global economy comes down and it could
uh this is a mutual Destruction for all
of us and then cyber now we see we have
huge if you think of the internet if the
internet were to go down
we would be in worse shape than we were
in the Middle Ages I mean middle ages
people could go grow their own food out
there you know whatever it was 100 few
hundred million people on the planet
eight billion people can't go out and
grow their own food if I ever goes down
if the internet went down there's no
banking system there's no nothing your
utilities your banking your food your
water everything runs on the internet
right so we have to preserve that and
we're screwing around with it with cyber
attacks and all the other stuff and if
you read the financial times today the
former senior military official in the
UK talks about the vulnerability of the
underground undersea cables 95 of all
the data in the world travels on
undersea cables and the Russians have
developed a very sophisticated way to go
down and cut those cables and as he says
Putin knows they're vulnerable they're
only 200 of them and that would bring
down the internet I mean so we have to
think hey we have to we have to globally
protect the environment and the climate
we have to protect the global economy
then functions we have to maintain the
Cyber system that we are totally
dependent upon I mean you know these
things go down and that's the end of our
Lives we can't go out and grow our own
food right and then of course we have to
not blow ourselves up with nuclear
weapons which was the original idea so
we are involved we are in a system where
we're kind of blowing apart a system
that we're all dependent upon and so
what point I mean you asked the question
that I think is exactly the right
question I don't even have an answer
because I don't know how it's going to
evolve I mean we used to have pretty
serious cooperation with China I mean I
was involved in it even in the military
sphere and uh you know there was a real
Good Will on both sides I think to try
to work on climate and a lot of other
issues so I did a report with the Asus
society called a road map for U.S China
collaboration on climate change and
energy and we really worked the Chinese
didn't co-author it but they we
consulted them we spent a lot of time
with it we ran all the the policy
recommendations past the Chinese and
that was our co-chair was Steve Chu who
became Secretary of Energy the John
holdren who became the science advisor
to President Obama we had the Todd Stern
who was the negotiate climate negotiator
was part of it we have very senior
people on the Chinese side who were
consulted on this it became the basis
the recommendations were in the who
didn't tell Obama joint communique in
2009 November 16th to communicate and
there was all this will we've had
probably a hundred collaborations
between the US government and China on
energy and climate since
1979. so there is this whole basis it's
there that is all being kind of blown up
at this point and I mean I I put the
biggest
concern about Xi Jinping has taken China
in a direction I do not think it had to
go where you know he was terrified that
the party was losing control and wanted
to consolidate party control use the
United States as the the evil you know
Empire to be attacked and to to be uh
the enemy to unite people internally and
you see the Crackdown in Hong Kong and
then and xinjiang and all this uh I
don't think it's popular in China my
friends in China who I know who I've
been impacted with for nearly 40 years
are not happy about this I hope there's
a change but I would say for China they
need friends climate change is hitting
China very hard they have severe drought
they had an unbelievable Heat Wave this
last summer the Glaciers are melting so
that the water situation is going to get
just where sea level rise is going to be
a real threat to to uh much of the
coastal China Shanghai and the
demographic collapse of China their own
Shanghai Academy of social sciences
predicted to just did a report came out
this year that this this coming year
they'll start to decline in population
and then China will go from 1.42 billion
people to 587 Million by the end of the
century that's a collapse that's going
to be old people with very few young
people who's going to do the work I mean
you go on and on they face real problems
well you need friends you need to be
working well with the world you need to
cooperate I mean we face all our
problems too so I'm not just putting it
on China I'm saying managing of 8
billion people on this planet all their
needs their concerns their fears an
economy that works for them and
maintaining this is something that we
could either lead to huge amount of
conflict it's your fault that I'm Mike
my my country is in trouble and or
within my country look at the United
States the kind of unbelievable attacks
on the Democrats from the Republicans as
if they're pedophiles and they're
destroying the country and all that so
within countries as situations
deteriorate you'll get tremendous
conflict and in between countries so
we're headed and awake it could be very
very disastrous the Ukraine itself could
turn into even a nuclear conflict I
don't think it will but it could and
it's certainly undermining Global so
anyway yeah yeah I'm sorry okay but
anyway it's a very uncertain period and
we need to figure out how to cooperate
and your generation okay let's have a
few more questions thank you thank you
sorry about that thank you I think I was
a next one so I have a question for
Victoria because I think looking at all
those Mega trends that all means for
everybody a lot of new things so
generally a lot of learning is and my
question is because you do Hands-On
activities with kids and you all said
the kids are the future they need to
learn the right things so I think I
would be interested to understand
um what are your key learnings about
learning what you have done here and
what of that is transferable to the all
the other countries in the world and
maybe are there also other
let's say Trends how people learn and I
mean not only technology but also
methodology and maybe also Society who
might be more open to see and include
maybe also younger ones so that would be
my question about Global Learning thank
you
yeah I because just just one more
because I think to understand and to
learn is the first step before you act
and we all want to see action and this
is why I'm so interested in learning
thank you yeah like the basis for for
this process is really three steps
really first recognize what is an issue
and problem and and therefore of course
you you need skills like first to
recognize then to evaluate what does
that mean uh in a context to me to
others and when we can analyze a
situation
then that enables us to take action on
it that's a bit like the structure
behind it of course it's not that easy
but I think it's really important first
of all to learn how can I inform myself
like also digital literacy like
um social media or in general
information what is uh what is a a good
source like on what can I trust and then
further on how can I
um if someone I don't know um
person a say something in the internet
for example I'm really shocked I have
family in Colombia and
recently we had elections and people
it's so like
a communication on social media is so
popular so so
um yeah even people who are educated who
are like upper middle class they so
easily fall on false statement and they
just send it like send it to other
peoples without even reflecting like
could that be real like they just take
everything absorb it and I think that's
that's the first step to really
recognize
um is this like like can I rely on this
information and then
then the next step is really um
yeah how can I how can I answer my
questions how can I where do I get the
information and then also the sentences
like how can I bring it together
what makes me able to to act and of
course this is really a it's maybe
sounds really easy in the three steps
but of course it needs also practice and
what I always the learnings I had is
really interaction group work like
um I was in a um yeah reformative school
and we we really from small on and we
had to do our own project our own
presentation
um
so I think group work and also the
relation or the the cooperation with
local organizations so that I also see
okay this is not just a school topic I
have to learn because my teacher tells
me or um but really how does this apply
in my context like where I can for
example growing food Urban gardening or
or inequality like how how maybe my
class the diversity like
um how come some people
um have different resources than other
so yeah and I think there was a second
question
the benefits of it
after learning
I think yeah of course the Ben you mean
the Learners themselves or
do we have a microphone
I was just asking so the the key thing
is the key learning is that they
um have to see the benefits of their
learning then it was efficient which is
normal yeah I understand this so my
second question was what about
institutions then so about the learning
of individuals yes I do understand if
you understand that you have benefits
from it you you you of course intensify
your learning what about institution is
there also learning and how to transfer
this to the to other countries Global
house Etc from your work female research
work yeah I think I mean I must admit
that really
um education for sustainable development
or climate change education
I really also in Germany sometimes feel
that it's not really taught in school it
really depends on teachers and and their
engagement but it's not really
um compulsory and in there and and the
plans of of contents so
um here I also think there are many
what we see is these bottom-up movements
like for example shoulder pattern or the
many other organizations in in the
climate change education field so
um I think this really has to be
institutionalized
um or example uh also on the book you
had an interview with um someone from
Brazil and there's also an organization
a teaching or teach the future I think
and and they really
trying how to incorporate Mega Trends in
in Daily class and not just have
external projects maybe where you can
reach some of the pupils but really
institutionalized in school system and I
think that's still missing like
a question
I'll do it shortly because I think we
don't have a much time my name is Andrew
I come from originally from Croatia but
I've been living here for three years
I work in the public broadcasting
institution ird and I'm responsible for
the strategy of program there along with
my team and this discussion is very
interesting in what Victoria said about
young people and that interests me the
most and I don't even know how to
summarize my question but I'll try
um
from my perspective of these Mega Trends
and what I was born in 95 so I'm in the
brink of this two generations and
everything and
nowadays I have a lot of contact with
young young generation and for some
reason when I look back at my parents
and some of the panelists here which
lived in in when these Trends didn't
even exist
I consider that we maybe in the past
lived for something and that we pursued
some other dreams and it was a bit
slower and everything was more
I don't know how to even explain it it
made more sense and nowadays we live in
these fast food cultures which just
arise one day and what Victoria said
just one day something pops up and it's
simply a Megatron and it involves the
whole world world and from my
perspective I think we'll live really on
the edge of both sides so it's either a
war and crime and completely no
democracy on the other side you are you
live in a big city you can change your
job in in one day you can you have
access to everything
and for me it's it's just I'm worried
what would we leave for this new
generation how will these these Mega
trends that influence this younger
generation because
yeah what is this shaping up for the for
the younger people
um and me the the other question is
actually how the mega Trends influence
influence megatrends itself I mean can
some of these Mega Trends influence each
other like migration
influences inequality and democracy
health and nutrition and and so on so
maybe if you can give a perspective on
that and of course the young people
because
the the money is power and nowadays I
see a lot of um young people who don't
have access to education on the other
hand are very smart but unfortunately
not wealthy and able to
you like I said access anything what
they want for their future and on the
other hand you have people who
in one week become I don't know what the
biggest magnets of this whole economy
and everything and you have people like
I'm just gonna name it Elon Musk
who want to show I don't know some kind
of power with the money and these like
latest news with everything for example
just a recent example with Twitter
takeover and everything I've been
following that for the past days he he
took over one con one company in order
to
maybe have a better Democratic view of
social media or whatever on the other
hand he's in he's firing people on on an
email with memes and stuff like that I
mean that doesn't even comply with
anything that was mentioned here with
mega Trend so I'm just stunned by what's
happening now so maybe just a
perspective on that
I think Demetrius will take the answer
he coined the term Tech feudalism so
perhaps it didn't coin it but you you
refer to it absolutely not
okay so there's a couple of aspects in
there
um just short I think people want to go
to another panel
so what are we leaving I I got three
questions out of this the one was what
are we leaving for the next Generations
right I mean good question that's that's
kind of what we're trying to figure out
because there's these trends that are
kind of Larger than Life and we are all
involved in them and it feels like
sometimes you're just in this kind of
river that's flowing towards the sea and
it's inevitable you can't really latch
onto anything you just keep going now I
don't I don't think the world is as
polarized as we either are on the brink
of Extinction or or we're just living
very well because if you grow up I mean
I think we grew up around the same time
probably you have a little bit more
experience because I was born in 2000.
um but what I grew up with was
essentially kind of a decade up until
2008 where everyone taught me that uh
the history had ended everything is nice
there's no more war or at least we
didn't care for it now it's a little
more visible perhaps that all of this is
still going on and we actually care for
it a little bit more
um so I guess the defining question of
our times is will we kind of acknowledge
these Trends and try to shape them
ourselves or will we just kind of move
along and let people who have a little
bit more power and maybe now we can
transition to the Twitter question what
happens when you have all this power
happens when you have all of this money
and you are driven by sheer ideological
you know conviction because the Twitter
takeover is a great example of there's
no substance to it there's really
nothing behind it the the musk does not
necessarily believe in anything he has
an idea of what Free Speech should be or
what you know the the pub what was he
call it the public
let's call it Agora should look like but
it it it's not really that it's more
like free speech for the people for his
followers and so that's where I guess I
think I was also told by my friend Shane
that techno feudalism was a coined by
varufakis uh nice coincidence there but
that's where technofutalism comes in
because we are already living in a very
much centralized social media media age
where Facebook basically owns Instagram
owns WhatsApp owns Facebook of course
meta let's say and then you have the the
upcoming projects to try and save face
from the fact that they never really
developed their social media as they
should have to you know not cause Wars
not cause Civil Wars not kill people not
allow hate speech on their platforms and
now this extends over to Twitter and so
all of these spaces one by one are kind
of you know leaving or reach and then we
can't really save them
um because obviously there's there's
quite a lot of good suggestions out
there for example to kind of
collectively own these social media
platforms but that requires a lot of
power and that requires a lot of you
know organizing but if you have billions
and if you can borrow against your own
shares you don't have to do any of that
because you can just buy the platform
um and I guess on the question of
influencing one another I guess I should
have also made that more clear this is
another great example that we have is
the example of Ireland and it's what
happens when you have free water a lot
of natural resources and a data center
wants to come in well what happens in
Ireland is essentially that once you add
an extra data center you're basically
adding an extra small Irish town to the
electricity grid and then you require
about 500 000 liters of cooling per day
for these data centers and that of
course has implications for inequality
because to attract those very data
centers you need to have lower taxation
sorry taxation rates you need to be
attractive to those multinationals and
that's kind of how you get this this
unequal society and you you kind of lose
control over it because then you know
Irish water comes out and says you
people should actually be saving water
and then the people respond you should
not be giving our water to a new data
center every once in a while and so of
course and then every single Mega Trend
once you apply the lens of another on
top of it becomes a whole new concept
kind of so hopefully I answered some of
your
questions I'd I'd like to get in here a
more hopeful note
um I have a friend who's a science
fiction writer Kim Stanley Robinson who
wrote a book that was published a couple
years ago called the ministry for the
future
and before he wrote the book he said I
want to write a book that's where things
go right where we solve
problems rather than just because so
much of Science Fiction now is this kind
of dystopian crazy but this book is
extraordinary because he really knows
his science his climate it's a really
climate change book and he knows his
economics and it takes place starting
about three years from now
um and it goes through 2050 and I always
say to him you know well it's it's kind
of a plan you know he gets to 2050 where
we're now on a rewilding we're we're
bringing carbon out of the air we're
we're getting a more equal and uh viable
economic economy so we're more towards
sustainable economic and environmental
uh path for Humanity uh so he's trying
to look well how would we get there and
I think it's it's I really recommend the
book Obama loves a book it's gotten a
lot of attention but it's called the
ministry for the future and the ministry
the minister happens to be who gets
appointed happens to be Irish she was
the former Irish foreign minister and
she's supposed to represent the future
future people future Flora and Fauna of
the planet in current policy so that's
sort of the idea and two things off just
add about it one is it's got the most
powerful opening uh description of what
climate change could mean that I've ever
read it just takes place at the
beginning in India with a a wet bolt 35
degrees of heat wave over this area
where millions of people die and but you
see it through the lens of this one guy
who's trying to help people and you it
really gives you what instead of looking
at temperature rise or anything here's
what could be like for human beings and
of course the heat wave that we've had
in India last year had a lot of this
element so it gets you that's why they
create this ministry for the future and
the other point that's interesting is he
really focuses on changing the
incentives in the economy so the
minister is out there convincing the
central Bankers to adopt something
called carbon coin where you get paid in
carbon coin to sequester carbon or to
not burn the carbon that you control to
rewild you change the whole incentive
system within a capitalist system of
sorts and you get people to do the right
thing they get rich from doing right
rather than harm to the planet so that
it brings back the idea that we can
change the system we can if we they
can't understand what alternatives are
how it is working how it's not working
properly and find new Pathways which of
course you younger people have a nice
day you're going to have them it's
pretty messed up good luck but you know
there's Alternatives and I I urge you to
kind of look to Alternative positive
Futures too I mean it's not all all bad
yeah I think we're having a really good
discussion let's go on for about 10 to
15 minutes we could have this wonderful
room until 11 30 but I think let's uh
try to be uh yeah let's try to have a
few more questions and
Stefan yeah and here
yeah I I think I have to leave earlier
but I don't want to leave a
without this question and your answers
chef and I work for peace NGO
through Global education
the question I need answers from you
guys is what gives you hope you as Mega
Trend experts I would not want to leave
this room without
hearing from you guys what gives you
hope
and I would appreciate if your answer
could be brief and if your answers could
the the speaking time could be evenly
distributed among the four of you thank
you that's a challenge I know
thank you
selling point of our book is that we are
more critical or we also include
critical thinking and critical aspects
on megatrends but that doesn't mean that
uh we are pessimistic so I pass on to
dimitrios right
um I'll be I'll be very brief I think
how incredibly smart young people are
and how well educated
um young people are and I'm actually
excited to hear what Victoria has to say
on this because I think I don't I don't
see the mega Trends and think to myself
oh someone's going to come up with
um we're going to solve inequality
easily that's that's not what I think is
happening but I think people are
educated enough and there's enough
Solutions out there to the point where
someone at some point and that idea will
find the right person and then we will
have we will build a better world and I
think that starts with kids
yeah um I think yeah we live in a kind
of a knowledge Society you know like we
we have a lot of knowledge but of course
you have to evaluate like what you need
from all this information and education
I I really believe is key but of course
education is also linked to inequality
so
um through your social status like um
it's not open for everyone so there are
restrictions yeah limited to your your
origin and um
so
um I think it's getting better and
access to education is is growing but
still there are restrictions the the
Wired Magazine had a covered about 15 20
years ago and it had this young school
girl in a little uh schoolgirl outfit
she's about 10 or 11. and she had won
the national she was the smartest kid in
Mexico won the national math contest and
she lived in a slum right at a by a
garbage dump
you know and that was the point and I
think that there's the Joy's law there's
a guy named Bill Joy who was a computer
guy and Joy's law was most of the
smartest people don't work for you and I
say it most of the smartest people are
not in the United States or Germany or
any you know it smartness is kind of
distributed among all human beings and
you know they're we're like five percent
of the population of the world in the
United States or six so all those smart
people are out there who are not getting
the chance so many I'm like this well
this young girl got some publicity but
really that that's the problem how do
you get this all these people have the
you know if we mobilize all the smartest
people in the world to focus on on
climate or something you might come up
with some great Solutions but they don't
even have a chance to be part of the the
dialogue in in so many countries in so
many parts of this country or the United
States so this challenge is really
critical yeah that also brings us a bit
back to the the the gender question or a
general diversity question of course I
think if we would have more perspectives
on on the future on Mega Trends or what
should shape the future then also the
solution would become that more diverse
like oh yes and I think we have a lot of
positive change happening I mean these
days I've attended a couple of
conferences on digitalization and
sustainability I think there's much more
awareness now within the digitalization
community that they have that
digitalization has to work uh in the
context of sustainability yeah the bits
and Boiler conference here at Ohio
University at Technical University
Berlin for example yeah and we see more
ethical commissions
engaging in in you know in ethically
inspired regulation for uh
yeah biotechnology
and Technologies and so on
and even in sustainable Finance I think
we have a relatively strong green
Finance sustainable Finance movement
with a new taxonomy of course there's a
lot of green washing but we have a lot
of Civil Society organizations
critically monitoring what is happening
and the German government has issued a
report Shifting the trillions towards
the the trillions of the financial
industry the Pension funds yeah not all
to the towards sustainable development
directions that would have not been
imaginable I think 10 15 years ago it
was just a bunch of
activists you know advocating for green
finance and that has now developed into
a kind of a movement and not only in
Germany I mean I I reviewed a master
thesis comparing green Finance in China
and in Germany yeah and sustainable
Finance green Finance is one of the
chapters in this book and uh with two
contributions of professors from the
etiha Zurich it has very prominently
represented here at the Berlin science
week I think there are lots of positive
signs out there
but I would add here that that you know
if you had a depression you can come out
of it there's a lot of things you can
come back from but climate change is
just moving right on whether if we you
know if we ignore don't move fast enough
it's not it doesn't care what we do it's
just gonna happen and we're headed
towards some pretty serious tipping
points so the question is whether we're
doing enough fast enough it's not
because I totally agree that a lot is
happening but the we're we can't say the
climate change hold on a minute you know
stop doing that we've got to get our act
together it's just going to keep on
happening whereas if you've had a
depression you can come out of a
depression you can come back from it but
you know a global nuclear war and
climate change are existential threats
that you're not going to come out of you
got to deal with them and either prevent
them or mitigate them so we've got a
very big challenge ahead and uh you know
let's let's hope that we we can meet it
but the geopolitics that you were
suggesting is a real impediment right
now uh to work to to focusing on what we
really need to focus on there's a hell
of energy I just think of the the the
the money going into militaries the
impact of the Curtin conflict just in in
terms of emissions and the diversion of
energies and and ability to cooperate
because of wars and Geo geopolitics so
geopolitics is becoming a very big
enemy of cooperation on climate and the
other issues
but we should not let it overshadow each
and every Avenue of cooperation not at
all it should make its first of why we
have to do it yeah are you have a
question there you're holding your
question card
okay
I'm a physicist and a science
communicator and I have a question what
about the New Media the role of the New
Media in this discussion is it enough
because the New Media the social media I
would say
tend to not to to deal about these Mega
trends
what is your opinion
I I we just want to take this one do you
want to start well I would just say that
there's so much focus on current issues
and and divisions and and War and you
know to get people to look at the bigger
picture is very hard I mean it's it's a
space-time problem from let's let's put
Einstein in here but it's a Time
space-time problem the space is is
geographical at issues and time is
looking out from the past into the
future how do we we bring those together
and find understanding and solutions and
focus people on those
I'm not optimistic at the moment I hope
we can get there
hi uh I just wanted to ask
um and thank you very much for the talk
and the interesting discussion so far uh
what so when it comes to Future research
and mega Trends in general what is the
role of or can there may be more of a
rule of uh developing economies because
I think the bricks which have been
mentioned a few times here thus far are
more the exception rather than the rule
so when it comes to smaller economies
that really struggle to make much
economic impact and have much of a
footprint on the world and politics as
as they're developing thus far
um are there ways that uh that they can
that they can shape the trends rather
than just be purely shaped by the trends
because we see now recently especially
with events such as covid
huge huge impacts being
disproportionately
um affecting towards really small
economies even just Sri Lanka as
compared to the uh larger example of of
the one of the bricks India
um and I'd like to briefly ask as well
hopefully this is quick uh has has
anyone's chain has anyone's thinking
changed in very recent times because I
realized that the book itself has come
out some months ago since then uh
there's been destabilization of uh
politics within the United Kingdom for
example uh there's been I mean even some
time ago the invasion of Ukraine so this
is there a lot of extremely influential
events happening in a very recent time
frame has this changed thinking on Mega
Trends or are the mega Trends and this
field of research
um
flexible enough that they already
accommodate for these types of events
when it comes to inclusiveness uh let's
get back to the 2030 agenda for
sustainable development of the United
Nations I mean
even me having worked on United Nations
policy for a long time I was very
positively surprised how this 2030
agenda with the 17 development goals
developed in such a powerful reference
framework all over the world I mean it's
not a western concept which has been
imposed on the United Nations and then
to some African countries it's really a
very inclusive agenda and a lot of
projects cooperation projects but also
other projects and and companies in all
parts of the world startups in all parts
of the world are referring to it and it
is there's a lot of support to keep it
as inclusive as possible and no
government has dared to back out of this
agenda even not Russia by the way you
know and even not Trump
so
I
I want to stress the importance of This
Global reference framework and in a way
the mega Trends framework is perhaps
most interesting for this strategy
consulting firms for business and
investment opportunities but we wanted
to make a contribution to also at make
it more comprehensive and to adopt a
more critical and inclusive approach
towards towards megatrend lots of
destabilization has happened yes but
re-stabilization will also occur well it
whether it will be better than before or
worse than before I mean I must admit
that I foresee serious problems I've
always highlighted the inequality
challenge I think we are we have not
seen the end of the road it will many
mega Trends including inequality also
climate change will accelerate in the
next years come and we have to really
put
all our efforts join hands at the global
level to to fight these these big
challenges and
sometimes people react allergic when
they hear Mega Trend maybe the mega
trend is like a tsunami it will just
overall me I I just have to be passive I
can't do anything but that's why we also
put a lot of emphasis on the role of
Shapers you know on think tanks and come
across with these little bit theoretical
proposition that everybody can be a
shaper can make a contribution and our
book resounded very well among people
who have who work with young people with
with children you know like Victoria and
a few others you know children for a
better world a big foundation run by the
by the bimwee and language
foundation in Munich they also
approached us they want to organize a
big youth congress next year here in
Berlin and also work with our book
so I think I'd I'd like to answer your
respond to your question too a little
more hopeful thing we we were just very
interesting Africa meeting yesterday
here at Berlin science week
we're going to see a lot of solutions
coming from small countries or just
individuals out there we have a trim we
didn't really talk about as the
democratization of technology and this
technology is making what I have written
for unctat about a better cheaper faster
scalable approach to development instead
of building huge world bankers built
build a beach huge power plant for a
billion dollars takes 10 years well
instead of that you do scalable solar or
scalable
power water purification plants that can
be done in every village or something
there's a whole one the technology is
making possible an approach that's new
and different secondly you're going to
see a lot of innovation coming
especially Out of Africa we've already
seen that and you know within PESA and
mobile payments and stuff but the other
Trend that I think is is I is this is a
trend I'd like to see encouraged but we
are moving I call it Peak globalization
that the amount of stuff physical stuff
be moved around on the earth is actually
I think already peaked but it will
decline that is liquid fuels food you
know toys and and cars all this stuff
that we move we can do more and more
production of energy food and products
where they're consumed which would have
hugely beneficial environmental impact
you're not moving this crap all over the
world it would have potentially huge
impact on equality inequality because
you'd have local jobs but just think of
it
renewable energy you don't move
renewable energy around the world and by
the way the one thing nobody ever says
the fuel is free forever you never pay
for the Sun or the wind you're not
paying Russia or Saudi Arabia or Texas
for your fuel every day like an addict
why we don't make that argument about
Renewables I it's beyond me from an
economic Point why do you want to pay
for the fuel you have to pay for the the
you know the the
solar panels and all that and the grid
but not the fuel secondly you can
produce more and more food locally with
vertical farms for the new technologies
you know cultured meats and all that but
more connection between the rural areas
and the cities through self I mean
there's all kinds of we've written about
this problem so you could do more
production of food where it's consumed
and then with 3D printing Advanced
manufacturing AI you'll probably be able
to make a lot more products where
they're consumed so you move less stuff
around there well I think that's a
better much more sustainable and
resilient world but it's also
technologically possible and will get
better over time and should be the focus
and that gives more potential for small
countries to not be dependent totally on
getting their energy from Saudi Arabia
or getting all their food from from the
Midwest of the United States or their
products well from China this has
changes the potential for how we
organize the global economy that would
be a far more sustainable and far more
I think equality and more local as Marx
would put a local control the means of
production so you know there's we have
to think in these ways that can harness
technological trends that already exist
and also look to the Innovation coming
from people in these other countries
that are not you know the big countries
and in the wealthy countries but they're
going to find ways to do things we never
thought of that might be much better
including in health care so there's a
lot of things out there that I think
could give us some some hope and that we
need to harness trends that are that are
already you know uh foreseeable but we
have to see them and say hey this is a
better way to do things bending I think
we have to wind up we are getting signs
here from the technicians waiting for
the next thing thank you very much and
we have a few copies available and also
the the Flyers here
all right thank you
well this was fun